hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the joy of creation now
this game was made by the same developer
of those nights at Rachel's which is
game that you guys have requested a lot
and I'm still debating on whether I'm
gonna play it but this one caught my eye
because it's made in Unreal Engine and
there's two parts this is a demo and the
other demo of the playable version that
was made more recently is actually a
free roam game now I don't know what
this one's all about but I wanted to try
this one first because it was made first
I honestly don't know how to play I'm
trying to read W games are apparently my
head is just on a swivel these cannot
fix
there and I'm afraid d-dad
with what I
like frankly I don't want I don't know
how to play Oh Lois lose it huh what was
it
doors open well god I don't how to play
Hey what do i do oh god I don't know how
to play seems a little unfair okay it's
gonna hone down the volume okay so now
that I know how to play and I'm not
gonna blow out the microphone with my
girlish screamin uh its W to move
forward and then it's right mouse button
to use your flashlight which I didn't
know that there was no prompts to tell
me that is helpful that's extremely
helpful actually Oh lovely door - dad
that's convenient ours
I'd recommend inventing
if these these kid not fixed
the mainframes our ferry I have a brave
deed an apartment put on
go Frankie I don't want that
yes of course go
or the call make sure you know Mike
okay all right now that we're back in it
and apparently we're just in a swivel
chair spinning it a girl
what oh hi
I saw you there holy [ __ ] bags whoa okay
whoa I don't like this oh this is the
opposite of good ah seriously it's a bit
it's a bit jovial with me just spinning
in a goddamn circle whoa whoa okay hi
bye thank you have a good I wasn't ready
but didn't know I didn't know that I
didn't needed a group swivel longing and
spam in my flashlight good god well this
game is freaking interesting for being a
demo that was made in four days not bad
honestly not bad also in case you didn't
know is [ __ ] dark in my room that's
something that I haven't had in a lot of
horror games that I've done in the more
recent past I used to do two all the
time
right now I just have a single desk lamp
illuminating my face and is frickin dark
in my room so atmosphere is a very big
thing when it comes to horror game the
fact that I feel uncomfortable in my own
room is a good sign that this is gonna
be good can I skip this please
oh I didn't realize you'd be coming out
so soon well okay no one's in the closet
Hey
well that was weird okay whoa geez whoa
geez bro
oh geez I don't know if there's any
sound cues from you just goddamn [ __ ]
things around me just gonna spin in a
goddamn swivel right well god with the
thing it's a little delayed on the view
Steve sir okay nothing yet who our God
it's gonna keep spinning just keep
swimming spinning just keep spins women
oh [ __ ] okay nothing there I would use
our hey oh yeah you better close that
okay so the real one that the only one
that gives me a goddamn clue of what's
going on before it happens is the window
and that right door so if there's
nothing there
ooh thought I heard glad who's that - I
thought I saw something above me did you
guys see that
I see y'all [ __ ] oh nice huh baby
maybe he's just one of the shadows being
cast on the wall I'm not 100% sure about
that okay probably yeah yeah so that I
can tell this I can't tell where's our
goddamn closet where there's an
animatronic just sitting there waiting
to come out and shout boo it doesn't
seem like sound hey [ __ ] off business
practices [ __ ] see this is what I like
it's mean what was that oh that was a
sound that's right back off okay I don't
know what with the one in the back okay
nothing there nothing there
check that okay Hey survival mode is a
[ __ ]
who's that guy here huh gotcha you do
okay no you don't want to join the party
all right
hi I see you there what's going me
what's calling me yes
god
there
issues with the toys and the skeleton
no time
this one is very very disturbing target
money
so fire house rather creepy and ended
with I really am so sorry I was more
frustration than actually being scared I
was like [ __ ] but how was I to know that
was so quick it's so slow turning around
how am I to know there's no clues it
must have been just opening when I
passed it over I'm gonna give that one
more go I'm gonna I want to do it one
more time this is actually really good
like I will admit this is pretty good I
like it I like it a lot
now the other joy of creation those made
more recently if I didn't mention it it
features free roam which is a whole
different experience from what I've done
before but this is by the same person
shut up I don't know I don't know at all
oh where is everybody
whoo see I really don't know if there's
any Sun boy okay
that door opens quick I'll tell you what
oh hey how's it going anybody back there
okay yeah this is whoa but this made by
the same guy that made or girl I have no
idea that made those nights at Rachel's
and if those nights at Rachel's is
anything like this game oh
what the [ __ ] goddamnit I'm bad yeah I
don't know how you do it I'm just
spamming and everyone maybe spamming at
everyone is causing it to do it more I
have no idea
ok alright anyway so I'm trying to
listen to audio cues but that door that
door was freaking sigh lens oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
whoa Nelly whoa Nelly whoa Nelly
whoa Nelly whoa Nelly whoa Nelly whoa
Nelly was that I heard something
something happened fine okay thousand oy
oy i don't know that was all about Oh
someone's trying to double-team me over
there Freddie and chica having a good
old time Oh chica not you not you are
you baby it's okay okay oh boy oh boy
whoa boy whoa boy whoa boy
okay I got you good I know I know what
you do
whoa whoa is that why was there a bird
uh
whoa
I'm okay that showers a sound I'm gonna
soon no damn it
well [ __ ] off whoo yeah I'm going as
fast as I can click guys whoa that was
the thing okay I want to make it to the
second phone call hey okay got you whoo
whoo whoa my head's just saw a permanent
Exorcist cycle just spinning in a
goddamn circle over and over and over
again passes I can go I know no other
way to beat this thought I saw something
okay
that was a close one whoa that was close
oh okay I know oh god it's been her own
ah [ __ ] yeah okay here we go second
phone call see what happens here
there
issues with more ease into skeletons No
hey boy whoa goddamnit
this was very funny
I really am so sorry I had to have
I have no idea
got it or something
okay I had that guy something's getting
out of hand but I'm kind of still
worried about what's going on in front
of me which is not good
whoa I think it's just high scores Adam
let's go Hanson it's got to get the high
score of not dying this which is always
a point of pride in my house put the
shells on my mantel
I put the reward on my shelf on my
mantel if they're not dying award it's
good goodbye okay
why is the leaf why was a leaf in here
okay so far so good
hi bye okay got that gang yeah okay
everything's okay
I think the spamming technique is
working as with everything in life just
mashing it as hard as you can it's your
success happens I saw that I saw that I
saw you foxy back there do you want to
get me the answer is absolutely okay bye
Bonnie weird [ __ ] Bonnie [ __ ] okay
there we go good good good got that you
came up early like that whoa whoa is
that running sound oh god damn it
there's no warning for that one oh god I
was like open it was closed I swear it
was closed for GAD hello goodbye hello
my baby hello my darling hello
mMmmm man I magnin night night night I
see a [ __ ] army [ __ ] I see the [ __ ] ah
damn [ __ ] [ __ ] I damn [ __ ] I said I
damn oh my god I'm gonna die now holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh began look it out yeah we got eyes it
I'm okay
survived six minutes that's pretty good
man I just have to do six more hours
high score baby okay I'm just gonna I
want to see this
hi foxy hey hey how you doing that is
disturbing are you having a good time
come on in join the party the water's
fine just gonna keep going up on hey
foxy are you doing okay so that is the
joy of creation but there's another
version of this game that's actually
free roam in a house and now that I've
seen this and this is just the demo made
in a few days that was awesome
so I'm gonna play the next one in this
game and then maybe maybe I'll play
those nights at Rachel's but the next
five nights at Freddy's game was
announced something about a sister
location so if you didn't know about
that there's another five nights at
Freddy's game on the way and apparently
it's not related to the main storyline
but it probably expresses the world or
expands the world so thank you everybody
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
the darker spookier version of my webcam
and I'll probably be doing this for the
next few horror games that I played just
because it adds a lot more for me so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
scream horror Freddy why is it [ __ ]
ready what professor okay damn it why
there's so many things to keep track of
it's such [ __ ]